Madonna ragazzi è da Capodanno che sto
facendo feste tutte le sere Quindi eh
Scusate se ho delle occhiaie incredibili
sto registrando questo video l'8 di
gennaio che è il giorno in cui devo fare
entrare Ascanio tra fatti la porta come
vedete è aperta ma oggi non siamo qua
per parlare di feste ma per parlare di
dissing A quanto pare no Bellissima sta
roba se non lo sapete xMurry mi odia
mettiamo insieme questo puzzle di
dissing che parte da questo video di due
mesi fa nella copertina ci sono io Favij
virgola ma dai sceglie in pochi secondi
per un rapido Sollievo della diarrea
perché mi parte questo prima i video di
muri chi lo sa Ciao ragazzi benvenuti in
questo nuovo video Favij ha preso la
patente dopo eh 38 anni praticamente a
quanti anni l'ha presa tanti la
smettiamo di evidenziare questa cosa Eh
murry per favore Grazie no t-cross
Adesso noi ovviamente aspettiamo la
risposta di Lorenzo Innanzitutto
Smettetela di rompere il cazzo alla
t-cross ok È una signora macchia punto
da neopatenta chi studia per la patente
Ehm tipo non io sa che non si possono
guidare tutte le macchine del mondo
appena hai preso la patente quindi non
mi potevo prendere una macchina
qualsiasi ma dovevo stare nel limite e
la t-cross era la macchina più potente
che io potessi prendermi da neopatentato
ci sta come macchina Eh che cazzo volete
non lo so cioè domani fa un video
compare sopra un Ferraris Hahaha
de veggente non è una Ferrari ma
comunque si difende bene questo video A
parte che non sa guidare
Ma io ragazzi non commento neanche cosa
devo dire intanto 690 km di autonomia
per 190 o è diesel o diesel e mi faceva
anche 800 col pieno e queste questi
numeri Me li sognerò la notte perché con
la Mustang ne faccio la metà
di macchina ma compare devi vedere una
t-cross ma che
non so se andare avanti con questo video
perché potrei diventare cattivo a
chiamarlo la mia prima guida No la mia
anche le pubblicità gli do anche i soldi
cioè ma dimmi te a chi so guarda non te
la schifo neanche così almeno guadagni
di più è tipi di una macchina come la
mia
E questo video finisce qua Questo era il
video Molto gentile da parte di murry e
Giampi parte subito quello dopo c'è
scritto è lungo e ovviamente non si
parla di muri ma andiamo quindi alla ehm
Reaction Number Two Eccoci qua Favij mi
copia mi deride pubblicamente non ci sto
ragazzi non so onestamente cosa ha detto
Favij mi hanno detto che mi ha agitato
vorrei capire un attimo perché ogni
volta qualcuno mi deve diciamo smuovere
dalla mia seggiola Ma chissà perché
sarai mica perché mi hai Spalato la Mer
nel video di prima sarà quello murno ho
comprato una macchina è una Mustang con
il kit estetico Shelby piccoli video
finito C'è la mia macchina uno che
carica ancora i video in HD ha comprato
la mia macchina
qua Beh allora allora posso spara questo
video renderizza i 1.440 pi giuro solo
per farti un piacere L'ho detto sempre
io che l'avrei voluta cosa ti compri la
mia
comunque Murri porta una m Quello che
voglio dirvi è che questo qua non sarà
un video Hero sulla macchina non me ne
frega Anche perché credo che non saresti
in grado Lorenzo Ostuni visto che hai
preso la patente da tre settimane l'ho
tra Messico con la macchina
Vediamo la Mustang di Lorenzo Ostuni
Quindi questi sono soldi veri che io sto
spendendo
cioè la parcheggiata una Panda in sto
video di fianco e manco a farlo apposta
perfetto
[Musica]
Hai detto la cosa è esatta No no Non può
essere la tua macchina cioè non si può
sentire non è una cosa che stanno in
cielo né in terra
Questa è la mia macchina
Tu da che parte stai Io dalla partita di
Favij non avrei mai detto grazie
jumpingmurry
[Musica]
Cioè guarda guarda com'è proprio
inadeguato questo è vero Allora ragazzi
Questo Questo è veramente vero io dentro
la macchina
è una cosa imbarazzante sembra che l'ho
rubata su su GTA la stessa roba se devo
dire
i biscotti migliori per fare colazione
davanti è vero Ragazzi comunque fatto
colazione a mezzogiorno perché mi sto
alzando tardissimo da capodanno in poi
non sto riuscendo più a prendere il giro
sono le 3:00 devo ancora pranzare Però
col guanto cioè no lo sapete lo sapevo
che avrebbero fatto guardalo guardalo
guardalo com'è contento Allora ragazzi
non mi rompete le Anzi prima fatemi
sentire cosa dicono io io
uno che fa benzina col guanto Ma quando
vai a fare benzina vuoi le malattie vuoi
che i microbi che i germi penetrino
nelle mani fa parte del mondo dell'auto
ciclista
il guanto lo mettono lì non finisco mai
quei guanti perché non li prende nessuno
se non Lorenzo dai Quanti ce li fornisce
il distributore Ma hai visti perché sono
germafobi due cose non tocco la pompa di
benzina e la maniglia quando andate nei
cessi pubblici pisciate vi lavate le
mani e poi cosa fate uscite prendendo la
maniglia ok questa cosa Io non l'ho mai
fatta devo arrampicarmi sulle porte per
tentare di aprirla In modo tale da non
toccare la maniglia il guanto non lo dà
al distributore Cioè nel senso ci sono i
distributori che li danno ma sono più o
meno il 20% dei distributori che il
restante 80% non ha il guanto Quindi io
cosa faccio quando vedo un distributore
che ha i guanti rumori cosa è forte come
mio nonno
nemmeno le 10:10 alle 12:15 Madonna ma
questa è l'ora esatta ma chi ti monta i
video è un genio C'è da dire che quando
acquisti una macchina del genere c'hai
paura anche solo a sfiorare un muro roba
del genere quindi ti assicuro che per i
primi periodi sarò con due mani tipo
questa macchina ma che minchiata ah ah
targa prova
non è sua No è impossibile Ti sei fatto
prestare la macchina solo per dissarmi
nel video Lorenzo quella non è allora è
la targa prova e adesso vi dirò la cosa
più brutta Più brutta da quando ho preso
la macchina è questa non la posso ancora
guidare Quando acquisti una macchina la
mia è importata dall'America l'hanno
fatta In The Cult Eh tu sostanzialmente
hai una macchina importata e devi fare
devi seguire tutto un iter per farla
targare ho dovuto aspettare 30 giorni 30
giorni per farmi arrivare Eh la targa
italiana potevamo girare solo con la
targa prova Questo è comunque 5 auto su
cinque
passiamo
più bello che abbiamo preso in vita mia
neanche a scuola credo che sì allora il
discorso è che io non mi intendo proprio
ripeto di macchine ci sono un sacco di
altre macchine che costano tanto anche
come la Mustang Magari anche di più Non
lo so che vedo molto più spesso mi fa
strano che ne girino così poche Spero
che questo sia una conclusione del
discorso Favij versus Murri in
automobile arriverà un terzo contenuto
da parte mia è sua lui comprare la
Mustang e andremo in pista Appunto
perché lui non crede che io sia in grado
ma forse murrino sa che io ho avuto
esperienze in passato con dei piloti
d'eccezione che mi hanno insegnato come
si sta in pista ad esempio questo video
che ho fatto con Carlo science
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Vi ringrazio ragazzi per aver visto
questo video ringrazio muri per volermi
così bene anche Giampy Eh noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un mi
piace bella ragazzi
[Musica]